provost pelé républicain est un monsieur
alain chrétien merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie
vous avez estimé hier monsieur le
ministre devant un séminaire d'artisans
réunis à paris que le rsi était une
erreur or la semaine dernière étaient
examinés ici même la proposition de loi
de bruno le maire et de julien aubert
portant justement sur la réforme du rsi
le gouvernement l'a traitée avec mépris
et agressivité
cherchez l'erreur vous avez
systématiquement refusé toutes les
réformes que nous avons proposées sur ce
sujet en septembre 2013
j'ai initié avec mes collègues cas des
bourbons une demande de commission
d'enquêté parlementaire sur les
dysfonctionnements du rsi vous l'avez
refusé en février 2015 bruno le maire a
demandé la création d'une mission
d'information co signée par 107
parlementaire vous l'avez refusé que
demandons-nous la création d'un fonds
d'indemnisation les artisans ayant subi
un préjudice la création d'une procédure
de conciliation avant toute mise en
demeure la simplification du règlement
des cotisations
l'accord implicite de l'administration
en cas d'absence de réponse du rsi la
certification des comptes du rsi par la
cour des comptes et encore bien d'autres
idées que vous avez toutes refusées
alors monsieur le ministre si bien sûr
vous avez le droit de nous répondre
parce qu'on a bien compris le message du
premier ministre
cherchez l'erreur est donné nous de
vraies réponses merci monsieur détient
la parole est à madame touraine militait
affaires sociales de la santé des droits
des femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
puisque vous parler d'erreur l'erreur
elle est sur vauban l'erreur elle est de
votre côté
parce que moi je ne sais pas si vous
êtes amnésique ou irresponsable mais la
situation dans laquelle se trouve où
s'est trouvé le rsi c'est à cause des
décisions que vous avez prises et face
auxquelles nous apportons des réponses
depuis que nous sommes aux
responsabilités
c'est pour faire face aux difficultés
nées de vos décisions que nous avons
demandé à deux députés
madame bulteau et monsieur verrier de
nous proposer un rapport à partir duquel
nous avons annoncé un certain nombre de
décisions avec monsieur avec christian
eckert et martine pinville les décisions
ont été prises et je veux vous le dire
monsieur le député la priorité
aujourd'hui elle est à la stabilité et à
la simplification
nous avons besoin de conforter les
artisans les indépendants de l'eau
redonner confiance dans l'avenir de
favoriser de faciliter leurs relations
avec leurs régimes de protection sociale
dès le mois de juillet dernier des
centaines de milliers de ces
indépendants ont reçu des remboursements
accélérés plus rapides lorsqu'il avait
trop cotisé des médiateurs ont été
nommés pour traiter les cas les plus
difficiles
un suivi personnalisé des demandes des
entrepreneurs a été engagée et dans le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui a été voté leur
protection sociale en particulier leurs
droits à la retraite ont été améliorés
la semaine prochaine les installerait un
comité de suivi qui preuve permettra de
faire un premier bilan et des mesures
seront annoncées par le gouvernement
vous le voyez monsieur le député nous
agissons
vous vous faites preuve
d'irresponsabilité nous nous engageons
auprès des indépendants
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
socialiste république